and the names are on the bottom and the
league and the players association doing
a great job
williamson took it right into that found
in brandon clark you talk about
versatility on the defensive end
well-rounded on the offensive end
nice pass zion williamson got the dime
from holiday and scores
later went on to become the head coach
of the austin spurs
their g-league team here's ingram on the
wing
great footwork and tremendous finish
tough cover unique cover zion goes quick
with it and gets it to go off glass
dylan brooks
toler got it and that's what they need
from him
three-point shooting williamson with the
flush
ingram on the dribble good help by jaron
jackson jr
brooks a good wing defender against
ingram better offense
by bi here at georgetown he was built
like a brick wall
and for a program that defined itself by
defense
he was perfect for the hoyas no doubt
and one
quick crossover and drive zion with a
little magic
and he blew his tire he came out of his
shoe
after landing
malika what did jenkins say at halftime
to the grizzlies he essentially said
guys we are right there we are still
in this we need to stay focused love to
see it i think this is what david
griffin referred to the ramp up
and zion goes right through and by
valencianas
gentry talk about zion williamson's
basketball iq there's another
example of it great bounce pass to jj
redick and on cue
playing the long game with zion
williamson so he sits down
they lead by four as we approach the
midway point ingram has made so many big
shots
for the pelicans this year it calls for
it working against brandon clark
nice pass and finish in one
holiday on the drive
zion on the baseline got it to fall wow
how aggressive how good are the feet the
court awareness
ingram a quick three in rhythm and good
well this guy
he has a knack for hitting those shots
ingram
against anderson off the favor screen
a long two on the way he's in a good
groove right now